we begin this morning with President
Trump on the attack last night in his
first public appearance since Thursday's
historic house vote to formalize the
impeachment inquiry mr. Trump lashed out
at Democrats the news media and the
so-called deep State this happened
during a rally in Tupelo Mississippi for
the state's Republican candidate for
governor the pushback follows
depositions from 13 people who provide a
consistent narrative of how the white
house held back military aid from
Ukraine in exchange for damaging
information on Joe Biden Natalie brand
is at the White House where the
president returned late last night
Natalie good morning good morning Dana
and the president hit the road to
campaign for the Republican
gubernatorial candidate in Mississippi
but he also road tested his latest
impeachment defense while we're creating
jobs and killing terrorists the Democrat
Party has gone completely insane the
president told supporters in Mississippi
that impeachment would tank the economy
if they ever do anything bad to us if
they ever succeed in their wildest dream
which will never let them happen that
stock market will crash like you've
never seen a crash before Friday night's
rally marked the first since the House
passed a resolution setting the stage
for the next phase of the impeachment
inquiry House Intelligence Chair Adam
Schiff says transcripts of closed-door
depositions could be released as soon as
early next week and CBS News has learned
public hearings could begin mid month
with key witnesses likely to include the
White House's top Ukraine aide who was
on the infamous July phone call between
President Trump and Ukraine's leader
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
testified behind closed doors this week
that he raised concerns about that call
but was told to keep quiet we have no
choice we took an oath to protect and
defend our democracy
and that is what he hasn't made an
assault on the inquiry so far includes
more than 70 hours of depositions from
13 individuals as House Democrats probe
whether President Trump pressured
Ukraine to investigate political rival
Joe Biden in exchange for releasing
military aid there's never been any
evidence brought forward that the
president committed a crime there are
allegations by people who don't like the
president not one House Republican voted
for the impeachment resolution this week
but a new Washington post/abc News poll
finds Americans are sharply divided over
impeachment with nearly half saying the
president should be impeached and
removed from office and that poll found
a wide partisan divide on this topic and
while the presidential election is still
a year away there are a few big state
races nationwide on the ballot next week
that could be in early gauge as to how
the impeachment inquiry will affect
Republicans and Democrats that includes
a tight gubernatorial race in Kentucky
where the president heads on Monday but
first he's expected to head to New York
for the UFC fight later this evening
Michelle interesting times Natalie thank
you